مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه بتداعيات حرب اسرائيل على غزه
وفيها نسلط الضوء على معاناه النازحين في
القطاع لا سما في رفح جنوبا حيث فاقم فصل
الشتاء معاناتهم وهم يفتقرون اصلا الى
مقومات الحياه الاساسيه حيث وصف الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني الوضع هناك بالكارثي
وانه يزداد سوءا يوما بعد يوم مع وجود
مئات الاف النازحين وعجز الهلال عن توفير
المساعدات لهم لمناقشه هذا الملف سيكون
معنا من رفح مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوت كما
سينضم الينا من رفح رائد النمس المتحدث
باسم الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني في قطاع
غزه ونشير بدايه الى ان عدد النازحين في
القطاع بلغ وفقا لوزاره الصحه في غزه نحو
مليون و900 ال نازح يتعرضون للمجاعه
وانتشار الاوبئه والامراض المعديه مليون
ووم ال شخص في محافظه رفح التي تشكل
الملاذ الرئيسي للمهجرين كما قالت وزاره
الصحه ان اكثر من 900 ال طفل في مراكز
الايواء يواجهون خطر البرد الشديد والجفاف
وسوء التغذيه والامراض التنفسيه والجلديه
هناك ايضا 5000 امراه حامل تعاني من سوء
التغذيه والمضاعفات الصحيه اضافه الى 400
ال مصاب بالامراض المعديه نتيجه
النزوح نذهب الان الى مراسلنا في رفح هشام
زقوت هشام ارسم لنا هذه الصوره من
المعاناه الانسانيه نتيجه وصول الاعداد
الكبيره والاف النازحين الى
المنطقه الصوره ربما صعبه الوصف سلمى لا
سما وان اكثر من نصف سكان من قطاع غزه
باتوا يقطنون وينز نازحون في مدينه رفح
هذه المدينه الصغيره التي كان عدد سكانها
لا يتجاوز 300000 نسمه اليوم اكثر من
مليون و200 ال نسمه يتواجدون في رفح في
هذه البقعه الصغيره التي لا يوجد فيها
ادنى مقومات الحياه في ظل هذه الاعداد
الكبيره وايضا في ظل عدم قدره السلطات هنا
على توفير ادنى مقومات الحياه نحن نتحدث
عن مدينه صغيره لا يوجد فيها الان بنى
تحتيه تستطيع استيعاب هذا العدد الكبير من
السكان لا يوجد غذاء ولا يكفي هذا الغذاء
الذي يصل من خلال المساعدات لا يستطيع
الناس شراء المواد التموينيه وشراء الدقيق
من ال من مراكز التسوق لانهم لا لا تسمح
السلطات الاسرائيليه بادخال هذه المواد
الى قطاع غزه سوى عبر المساعدات وبالتالي
هم يحتاجون الى كل شيء لكنهم لا يجدون اي
شيء سواء في الاسواق وان وجدت في الاسواق
فان ثمنها باهض جدا خاصه ان المساعدات
التي تدخل هي مساعدات شحيحه نحن نتحدث عن
مليون و2000 نسمه يتواجدون في بقعه صغيره
جزء منهم في المناطق الغربيه المسماه
منطقه المواصي في رفح وهم متواجدون هناك
في ظل ظروف صعبه هذه المنطقه لا يوجد فيها
ادنى مقومات الحياه لا يوجد فيها بنى
تحتيه لا يوجد فيها مياه لا يوجد فيها اي
نوع من انواع الخدمات حتى الخيام التي
يعني ربما تكون ماوى بسيط لهؤلاء السكان
هي باتت غير متوفره في ظل ازدياد اعداد
السكان اعداد النازحين الذين اتوا في خلال
الايام الماضيه من خانيونس الجيش
الاسرائيلي يجبرهم على ترك كل امتعتهم
وترك فراشهم وترك كل ما يلزمهم وما حملوه
من مناطق النزوح في مدينه خان يونس
ويمنعهم من القدوم الى مدينه رفح وهم
يحملون هذه الاغراض وهذه الامتعه وبالتالي
جاؤوا الى مدينه رفح بلا امتعه وهم الان
في وضع كارثي لا سيما ونحن نتحدث عنهم
الان وفي ظل منخفض جوي في يضرب قطاع غزه
منذ ثلاثه ايام غرقت الخيام
واقتلعت من من جراء الرياح الشديده من
مناطقها ومن اماكنها لا يوجد متسع على
الارصفه تتواجد خيام ويتواجد نازحون على
في الشوارع في المساحات الفارغه في
الاراضي الزراعيه في كل مكان يتواجد
نازحون هربوا من حمم القصف الاسرائيلي لكن
القصف ايضا يلاحقهم حتى هنا في مدينه رفح
فمدينه رفح تقصف ما بين يوم واخر من قبل
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وتستهدف هذه
الطائرات دائما وابدا منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه هذه المنازل هي منازل المكتظه
بالسكان وكان هناك عشرات من الشهداء
والجرحى جراء هذه الغارات المستمره
بالتالي هي حياه كارثيه يعانون الامرين
ويذوقون وهناك معارك يوميه يلجؤون اليها
لانهم بحاجه الى الدقيق بحاجه الى الخبز
بحاجه الى المياه والمياه غير متوفره
بحاجه الى الدواء ونحن نتواجد امام مستشفى
هذا المستشفى كان يعني يقدم الخدمات يوميا
قبل الحرب الى 40 الى 50 من المرضى اليوم
يقدم ال خدمه لنحو 1500 من هؤلاء المرضى
500 منهم فقط من الاطفال في ظل انتشار
الاوبئه في ظل انتشار الامراض في ظل
انتشار البرد والبرد القارس بالتالي هناك
امراض شديده تحل بهم بهؤلاء الاطفال لا
سما ايضا النساء والرجال وكل هؤلاء
يحتاجون الى عنايه يحتاجون الى دواء وكل
هذا غير متوفر في رفح الان شكرا جزيلا لك
من رفح مراسلنا هشام زقوت وابقى في رفح مع
السيد رائد النمس متحدث باسم الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه سيد رائد
مرحبا بك معنا ما نوعيه الخدمات
التي من الواجب ان
تقدمونها في مثل هذه
الظروف اهلا بكم في الواقع تقوم طواقم
جمعيه الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني ومنذ بدء
هذا العدوان الاسرائيلي على قطاع غزه
بتقديم الخدمات الاغاثه الى جانب خد
خدماتها الصحيه والاسعاف التي تؤديها
طواقمنا ايضا هناك ولكن لم تغفل عن الوضع
الانساني الكارثي الذي يعاني منه نحو
مليون و900 ال نازح وهذا الرقم في تزايد
لان هناك موجات نزوح مستمره من المناطق
التي تسيطر عليها قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وتستهدف مجمعات سكنيه كامله او
احياء كامله وبالتالي ما يحدث في خانيونس
وموجه النزوح الثالثه لها في هذه الاوقات
ايضا تزيد من الاعباء الملقاء ال العاتق
مقدمي الخدمات الاغاثه ولا سما منهم جمعيه
اللي الاحمر الفلسطيني على مدار ايام
العدوان الطوال قمنا بايصال عدد من
المساعدات الغافيه والغذائيه وحتى الصحيه
الى مراكز الاواء التابعه لانور والى ايضا
مخيمات الاواء الاخرى التي هي خارج نطاق
عمل الامم المتحده وقمنا بالتخفيف من
معاناه النازحين هناك لا سما وان يعني
مراكز الاواه تفتقر الى ادنى مقومات
الحياه من ناحيه النوم المبيت السليم
التدفئه وحتى الصحه العامه والنظافه
الشخصيه وغيرها جميعها
مراكز تفتقر الى كل ذلك قمنا ايضا بانشاء
خمسه مخيمات ايواء في كل من منطقتي رفح
وخانيونس وذلك
لاحتضان مئات العائلات التي اصبحت بلا
ماوى وتعمل طواقمنا ايضا على تنظيم مثل
هذه المخيمات لتخفيف
الم منها الئ سيد
رائد ما الاعداد التي تستطيعون ان تغطيه
ان تغطو بالخدمات الاغاثه والصحيه
والاسعاف في ظل هذا الكم الكبير من النزوح
باتجاه رفح اكثر من مليون ووم الى مليون
ووم الف نازح
والاحتياجات تشمل كل القطاعات وهي يعني
عامه
يعني حقيقه محافظه رفع هي من المحافظات
ربما الصغيره في قطاع غزه والتي كان عدد
سكانها لا يتجاوز ال 300000 اليوم نتحدث
عن نحو مليون و300 ال اصبحوا في محافظه
رفح التي تعد مواردها شحيحه ولا تتناسب مع
هذا الكم الهائل من النازحين وبالتالي ما
يتم ايضا ادخاله من مساعدات عبر معبر رفح
البري جنوب قطاع غزه هي ايضا مساعدات
شحيحه لا تتناسب مع هذا الكم الهائل من
الضغط لدى العائلات النازحه والذين جلهم
من الاطفال والنساء هناك اكثر من
900000 طفل بين هؤلاء النازحين هناك اكثر
من 80,000 امراه حامل موجوده في مراكز
اللواه التابعه للامم المتحده هناك اصحاب
امراض مزمنه كثيرون وهم الاكثر عرضه للاسف
للاصابه بالاوبئه والامراض نتيجه هذا
التكدس وبالتالي من طبيعي جدا في ظل
هذه حالات النزوح الكثيره وفي ظل
افتقار الجهات الاغاثه الى المساعدات الا
تصل جميع المساعدات الى النازحين وان يكون
هناك يعني احتياج بالغ فبالتالي عديد من
العائلات وصلتنا مناشدات بانها لا تجد
مكانا تاوي اليه لا تجد
افرشه وتفترش الارض سواء كان في غرب رفع
او غرب خانيونس وذلك حقيقي للاسف وهناك
مشكله حقيقيه في الامن الغذائي والحصول
على المياه النظيفه والعلاج داخل هذه
المخيمات وبالتالي يجب ان يكون هناك تحرك
حقيقي من اجل احتواء الازمه وتلبيه
احتياجات هذه العائلات النازحه سواء كانت
الاغاثه او الصحيه والانسانيه والعمل على
وقف هذا العدوان الاسرائيلي اولا واخيرا
سيد رائد ما هي ابرز المخاوف لديكم يعني
طبقا لهذه الاحتياجات الكبيره والضخمه
والتي تشمل كل هذه القطاعات وهذه الفئات
خاصه مع تعليق كثير من الدول الغربيه
للتمويل للاونروا وهي عباره عن جهه رئيسيه
تعمل على موضوع
الاغاثه يعني كما تعلمون قطاع
غزه ربما هناك اكثر من 70% من سكانه
يعيشون تحت خط الفقر ويعانون من البطاله
وبسب ذلك بسبب الحصار الاسرائيلي المفروض
منذ سنوات طويله على قطاع غزه اي اكثر من
65% من سكان قطاع غزه يعتاشون على هذه
المساعدات ولا يوجد لهم مصدر دخل اخر
وبالتالي نحن والجهات جميعها العامله سواء
المحليه او الدوليه كنا نطالب بزياده
المساعدات وزياده
رقعه الاغاثه التي تقدم الى قطاع غزه في
هذه الاثناء ومن شان هذا القرار ان الذي
يعني يؤدي الى تقليص المساعدات ان يزيد من
حجم الكارثه الانسان سانيه هنا في قطاع
غزه بدلا من ان يعمل على زياده المساعدات
نتفاجئ بان هناك حديث يدور عن تقيص
المساعدات وربما الغائها وهذا بالتالي
سينعكس سلبا على حياه مئات الالاف من
المواطنين الذين هم بحاجه لكل مساعده وفي
هذا الوقت تحديدا الذي تتعرض له قطاع غزه
الى اكثر من 100 يوم من العدوان وما يزيد
ولازلت اله الحرب الاسرائيليه مستمره في
هذا العدوان يعني على سبيل المثال صباح
هذا اليوم قام الطائرات المسيره
الاسرائيليه المزوده بمكبرات صوت بمطالبه
النازحين في مستشفى الامل في خانيونس
ومقرها في خانيونس بالخروج وتحت تهديد
السلاح وتامر بالتوجه الى منطقه مواص
خانيونس يعني هذه الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
وعركه النزوح بحاجه الى مزيد من المساعدات
وليس تقليصها شكرا جزيلا لك من رفح رائد
النمس المتحدث باسم الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني في قطاع غزه شك المشاركه
معنا ختام هذه النافذه الانسانيه الى
اللقاء